what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with jerry dugan's x-men run as
we make our way into uh axe axe avengers
vs x-men versus eternals so here's the
thing as much as i love jerry dugan's
run this is the usual problem with jerry
dugan he's trying to cram too much stuff
into a singular story so there's a whole
other side story here that has to do
with game world and is completely
unnecessary for what we're talking about
here uh so i don't even know why it's in
here but uh we're gonna skip over that i
mean it is kind of the return of mojo
which i guess is kind of cool mojo
hasn't really been interesting since the
90s but the thing about this is that
this initially picks up with what is in
effect dr stasis now dr stasis was kind
of like this looming background villain
that existed over the course of the
first arc but we didn't really know what
significance he was going to have and
the funny thing about this is that the
way that jerry dugan presents dr stasis
he's not that dissimilar from the high
evolutionary in the sense that what dr
stacis has been doing is basically
modifying animals and almost making them
like anthropomorphic right like animals
that kind of function in the same
capacity as humans to a degree in the
sense that they're basically his
soldiers and so what ends up going on is
you have a being named bornen who
basically kind of operates as like his
tiger henchmen what have you and
effectively these forces these animals
once they consume this drink that's
basically been given to them kind of go
into an almost beastial sort of
maddening state and then are sent
forward into the world in order to
basically capture the genes or a being
that in a sense dr stasis is looking for
now we'll get this sorted out here in a
second what we end up doing here we do
get a kind of aftermath where cyclops
basically wakes up after his apparent
death and then he's basically told by
emma frost we really can't have you
going back out there as cyclops and the
question that we've sort of been
wondering for the last little bit is why
right what was it about the death of
cyclops that basically means that while
he is resurrected he can't really go
forward and be cyclops anymore and the
answer to that question came in the form
of the attack that was launched by the
forces of dr stasis that what ended up
happening is of course the x-men
responded now remember a lot of this is
because this attack took place in the
city of new york the x-men currently
have the treehouse which is their base
of operations in the city of new york so
of course it allows them to respond to
threats in new york faster than they
would if they were simply just on
krakowa and so arriving here cyclops
unleashes holy hell like he literally
goes nuts on these guys and does a
pretty damn good job of doing it right i
mean it's just manipulating the
direction of his optic blast and all
that kind of stuff he just goes full on
just losing on these guys which is
really amazing and in fact there's a
really good point a really good moment
that goes on here where everett thomas
who we'll talk about here in a second
everett thomas actually syncs with
cyclops and then uses his optic blasts
as well which allows them to basically
double down on these attacks now of
course x23 jumps in and the rest of the
x-men jump in and so on and so forth but
while all this is going on you basically
have dr stasis who's monitoring the
entire thing and he basically tells uh
born and his uh his main henchmen we're
not getting what we need i need you to
respond and that's when born and
basically jumps in right like literally
an explosion is caused and it basically
blows cyclops kind of out of the way and
this allows the momentary distraction
now while this fire is going on sync
like everett thomas actually syncs with
jean grey now this is a massive moment
here because when this happens sunfire
realizes what's going on and he's like
wait a minute wait a minute like how in
the world did you do that you synced
with jean grey and she's not even on
earth like how in the world did you
manage to pull that off now he passes
out almost immediately after doing this
which of course you know indicates it's
a huge strain on him but again this is
the kind of continued expansion of the
powers of everett right the idea that
like he can sync with people and that in
years past he could only do it with
people who were in his immediate
vicinity once they were out of his
acidity his ability to sync with them
basically vanished until they returned
eventually we were given this idea that
he could kind of tap into a quote
unquote memory of them but even then it
was limited what's going on here is that
essentially jerry dugan and marvel are
telling us once ever it syncs with
someone he can seemingly do it forever
but he can just always draw on their
powers over and over again now again we
don't really know the full totality of
this and in fact we'll see this shift as
time goes on right we'll see more about
how his powers function and how they
work as things progress just it just
makes logical sense but in the aftermath
of all this you do have an instance
where bornen goes after cyclops or
really goes after a younger kid cyclops
gets in the way saves this kid and then
is attacked by born and when that
happens he's severely injured but it
kind of leaves him out of the immediate
purview of the other x-men which allows
dr stasis to show up slice his throat
and then walk away and that's why it is
that cyclops basically can't come back
out again as cyclops as we know him
because his death was exceedingly public
everybody saw it happen and remember the
x-men are keeping the secret of
resurrection something to themselves
they're not really allowing anybody else
to know about it and in fact almost no
one else does know about it and those
who do know are basically keeping it
quiet at the request of the x-men hence
the whole thing with ben yurick and the
expose he was going to write in learning
that the x-men had solved the the
equation of resurrection so if cyclops
were to simply show back up again people
would know they can bring folks back
from the dead and everything changes
right at that point you're talking about
politics be damned it's a full-on human
invasion of krakowa to take the secrets
of resurrection again just kind of
arguing self-preservation right the
simplistic nature of humanity and so
with that being the case psychos
basically has to undergo the process or
at least adopt a new moniker which ended
up becoming captain krakow of course he
uses technology in order to achieve that
but again this is one of those things
people will kind of get pissy about it
but people get angry about this stuff
because they don't know anything about
comic books eventually cyclops is going
to go back to being cyclops so for those
of you guys who are new ignore the
naysayers in the comments section who
are like it's a problem when things
change cyclops is going to go back to
being cyclops right so ignore those guys
don't worry about them you know they
just don't know what they're talking
about they don't know anything about
comics so it's one of those interesting
things where we kind of get to see what
this is going to look like for a period
of time in marvel and i'm curious to see
where it ends up going now at this point
we basically switch over to a boat where
everybody's going crazy and killing each
other and the reason why is because we
essentially have something called
project amy right which is short for
project amygdala which essentially the
part of the brain that regulates the
fight-or-flight response that it's being
manipulated really using these people as
an experiment which is being recorded
but what looks like advanced idea
mechanics which is pretty gruesome when
you think about it and basically it's
the plot from 28 days later where people
are just going absolutely crazy with
rage and just massacring each other the
entire project is being overseen by
modoc because why not why wouldn't modoc
oversee overseas something like this now
of course the x-men respond and this is
one of the things to know the way that
jerry dugan is doing this is it's a
bunch of stories that seem disconnected
that will connect once you get to the
end of it right so it's kind of a
differing nature by the way jerry dugan
tells the story which is similar to
hickman just not as organized so the
thing about this
is that you basically have this kind of
ongoing plot while the x-men are here in
dealing with this this segment is not
overly important what is difficult here
is the struggle of everett thomas it's
the struggle of him in relation to laura
kenny because one of the things to
remember is that when they were in the
vault right the children of the vault
during jonathan hickman's run for those
of you guys who recall that when they
were in the vault and all that time had
passed for them they had spent a
lifetime together and while laura was
basically resurrected and she doesn't
really remember any of that ever it does
and everett recalls all those things
that they went through so for him he
lived a life with a woman that doesn't
know who he is anymore and as a result
of that there's a lot of pain and a lot
of struggle that goes on there because
he wants on one hand to sort of rekindle
that relationship but on the other hand
laura's like i don't know what you're
talking about right so it's almost kind
of him sort of trying to force himself
on her to a degree not physically but
the emotional attachment that he has for
her now of course once they get in there
they basically end up you know taking it
to
modoc you know basically just kind of
wrecking this guy essentially and of
course captain gracoa uses the
telepathic powers of everett who of
course has those powers due to the fact
that he's tapping into the abilities of
jean grey to effectively invade the mind
of modoc right and in doing so modoc had
always kind of played this game
historically speaking of he knows
people's most personal weaknesses he
knows how to target them specifically
that kind of a thing this moment here is
only really significant if you know the
history of modoc but the point the
bigger point here is that cyclops knows
the internal motivations of modoc
himself and the idea here is as long as
you stay away i'll stay away but it's
kind of cool because modoc has a sort of
family for himself that he fashions
having and different things along those
lines he's nowhere near as violent as he
historically seems to be but cyclops has
basically found his weakness right in
his heart of hearts what it is that he
desires most and the response to cyclops
is if you keep doing this if you keep
being this villainous guy who's engaging
in these crazy activities and whatnot
then we'll use this against you right
we'll literally break your mind and
we'll break down who you are by using
these things now the other question that
we had here was how it was that ben
urich who is going to publish the story
on how it is that the x-men have managed
to solve resurrection why he had
forgotten about it because we didn't
know exactly what had happened when
cyclops called him up and said hey i'm a
friend of cyclops you know and and so on
and so forth and i know what's going on
with the x-men and resurrection do you
have time to talk ben eurek's response
was i don't know what you're talking
about so in effect his mind had
basically been wiped or he had been
killed and secretly resurrected which i
think would have been a cool alternative
but what had actually gone on here is
that everett had realized what it was
that ben yurik had tapped into he'd
realized what it was that ben yorick was
doing in the sense that he had was
essentially going to write an article
about resurrection and it could have
entirely jeopardized everything with
krakow so whatever it did is he wiped
ben's mind now this is a really really
huge moment here because everett has not
really been a guy who would do stuff
like this everett's one of those very
few holdovers from the old generation x
stories where he was just intrinsically
a good guy he did a few morally
questionable things but nothing on this
level and that's why it's really sort of
a strange or really kind of a
mind-boggling situation to see him do
this because whatever it realized when
he basically showed up wiped the mind of
ben yurick and then took his notebook
and all his information is he realized
ben was not really going to write any
kind of a of a hack job on the x-men
right he's not like a modern-day news
organization where he's basically trying
to write things from a negative slant
instead what he was looking to do was
write things from like a more truthful
slant and in fact one that would
actually shine the x-men in a more
positive light but he didn't realize
what he had done and or at least what
was going to happen as a result of what
he done until he took the notebook so in
effect he had actually cost the x-men
positive publicity but more so than that
he had approached the situation from an
exceedingly negative standpoint when it
wasn't going to be the case and in fact
he really says like ben urich always
thought that we were miracles that he
really wanted to write the x-men or at
least write about the x-men and
resurrection in a positive way and
that's going to become very important
later on but it's one of those guilt
moments that basically everett has to
deal with as a result of what he's done
now the other part of this is modoc in
terms of his return as far as his
involvement with dr stasis and the
reason for this is that what ends up
happening is that while modoc's scheme
was just modoc being modoc and just
doing his thing it drew the attention of
the folks at orcas it drew the attention
of dr stasis and those guys now we
didn't initially know that stasis was
working with orcis we know that now but
it's one of those things where he's kind
of their scientific arm to a degree the
overall gist here and one of the things
to know is that ben urich's initial
knowledge of the fact that humans had
cracked the code of of resurrection had
actually been given to him by dr stasis
he's the one that sent him on that path
in the first place and that's kind of
their first stage right that that orcis
is a multi-pronged organization they're
simultaneously launching attacks against
the x-men on a physical front while also
doing it from a more political front and
the idea here at least on the political
level is to leak to a journalist the
fact that the x-men can resurrect the
dead and then have that become public
knowledge in the hopes that humanity
learning about that will lead to
humanity attacking uh the entirety of
the x-men now what humanity will need in
that moment is effectively some kind of
a leadership right someone someone that
can really kind of appear and say hey
we're the ones that can help you achieve
your goal of taking resurrection from
those mutants who are being selfish and
give it to the rest of society and so
orcas seeks to position themselves in
that role and dr stasis is the one
that's basically spearheading the effort
the other part of this is to actually
work in such a way to where they can not
only launch an attack against the mutant
population but also launch an attack
against humanity as well that's the goal
here with regards to what they want to
do in terms of bringing modoc in in fact
taking his project amy having modoc
basically spearhead the project and then
use it to attack the whole of humanity
that in doing so orcas can in one fell
swoop solidify control of not just earth
from the mutant population but also from
humanity itself and position themselves
as effectively demigods and so what you
get here is the different members of
orcis who are curious about it but
nimrod is the most curious about it and
nimrod's like okay i would like to meet
this modoc right i want to meet this
killing machine now as far as i'm aware
and i could be wrong here although i
don't think i am as far as i'm aware i
believe this is the first time in marvel
comics that nimrod meets modoc now this
is where a lot of the theories are
coming from regarding what the full
intention of orcus is with the mutant
population outside of having been uric
published some article about their
resurrection that if modok's technology
or his ability to manipulate the
amygdala and send people into a fit of
rage can be weaponized by orcis then
with krakowa presenting a kind of
unified front among the mutant
population the best way to bring them
down is to force them to fight each
other and the best way to do that is to
use project amy to essentially create a
giant kind of civil war among the
mutants that exist on cocoa which i'll
be honest the marvel universe already
had its civil war among all the
superheroes if you guys recall the x-men
were hands off they didn't want to have
anything to do with that they were like
nope there's so few of us already we're
not going to risk lives right because
remember civil war took place during the
events of decimation when all you had
was 198 mutants left so this would be a
phenomenal opportunity for marvel to
present us with an x-men civil war that
would literally be their civil war
pertaining strictly to them but nimrod
and dr stasis and those guys end up
breaking modok out of jail and then
bring him into orcus and that's where
things get really really intriguing
because following that one of the things
that happens here is there comes a point
when x-23 is basically resurrected right
not long ago on kakoa at the arbor
magnet which of course is where they
resurrect people one of the big
questions a lot of you guys had is that
when it comes to the resurrection
process how is it that someone like
wolverine is resurrected with adamantium
on his body right like if he's being
resurrected wouldn't he just show up
with bone claws the way that jonathan
hickman geniusly answered that question
was to use proteus remember proteus can
manipulate matter on the atomic level
but he can only do it in a localized
space right in a small space which is
kind of how marvel kept him in check
right creating a guy who could alter
reality but removing him from the
possibility of being a guy who can alter
reality on a universal level what
proteus would do is in the case of
someone like wolverine proteus would
basically have adamantium bonded to his
body because one of the things that was
established in the early days of marvel
comics when it came to proteus is his
ability to manipulate matter included
adamantium and all he needs is a sample
of it and so one of the funny things
here is they actually end up changing
the powers of laura kinney that when
x-23 is resurrected historically she's
only ever had adamantium claws her bones
are just normal bones when proteus
resurrects her he thought that everybody
who was basically based off wolverine
had adamantium bones so when laura
kinney's resurrected she's given
adamantium bones she has a skeleton
structure just like wolverine does now
which is really cool it's one of those
small little modifications it's just
done kind of off the cuff and you
wouldn't really realize it unless you
were paying very close attention but it
is a cool little thing because now she's
got a whole new level of power and so
the other part of this is in a lot of
ways jerry dugan just kind of rounding
out and sort of bringing in characters
that we hadn't really seen for a while
we were kind of wondering where they
were what was going on with them in this
instance the x-men pick up on a mutant
signature that's essentially being held
in an orcis base and so they send laura
kinney in to basically retrieve that
person right because wolverine's doing
his own thing and laura kenny's part of
the official x-men team so it makes
perfect sense they would send her in
when she gets in there and she locates
where this mutant is she ends up
cracking open the uh the device that
holds this mutant and then she's a she's
like immediately attacked only for us to
find out it's lady death strike now for
people who are not really familiar with
their character it's kind of like who
but yuriko is a great character who just
doesn't really get utilized properly
right she just doesn't really get used
in the right way now one of the funny
things is for those of you guys who ever
saw x-men the animated series and you
saw the reavers their introduction came
by way of lady deathstrike basically
receiving her modifications that were
done by them in the comics they were all
modified at the same time right they
were actually on an island when it all
happened and it was a kind of a cool
story i guess in fact remains she's been
around for quite some time she's an
exceedingly dangerous person and in fact
she's able to go toe-to-toe with laura
kenny to a degree until laura basically
cuts off her arm and then that's when
you end up finding out that death strike
attacked her because she thought that
laura was working for dr stasis that's
kind of how all this is unfolding that
lady deathstrike has basically been been
manipulated and used by dr stasis for
his own ends she's of course brought
back to krakowa she undergoes the
resurrection process and then of course
ends up just kind of returning as she
normally does you know with her body
intact and so on and so forth and then
ultimately ends up leaving there are
some adjustments that are made to her
right we don't know the full extent of
those adjustments but for example her
hands are not gigantic adamantium claws
anymore so we don't know exactly what
direction her powers are going to go in
how she's going to unfold it's one of
those things where jerry dugan does this
to set the stage for her but this is one
of those instances where i talk about
how jerry dugan just tries to cram too
much stuff into a singular story right
he tries to put too many things in there
at one time and so switching back over
to cyclops and over to uh well really
with sync because sync is kind of a
swiss army knife of powers he's really
an omega level mutant at this point he
has not have been officially confirmed
but at the moment the x-men are
considering that right the quiet council
is like should we list this guy as an
omega level mutant and if he is how do
we categorize or where do we put him
like how do we do we keep him as part of
the main x-men team can we find a better
role for him different things like that
but i would surmise once his powers
reach their peak he's going to be a
one-man army right he's like the guy you
send in for basically anything and he
can copy the powers of anybody so we
don't know the full extent of that right
we don't know how far reaching that is
this is one of those instances where his
powers could become limitless but with
him and cyclops basically trying to
track down dr stasis and figure out
what's going on with this guy they
ultimately discover his lair of course
they're attacked by by borin and of
course that guy's dealt with pretty
quickly but one of the cool things that
happens here is sync is everett actually
syncs with uh with laura even though
she's not there and pops adamantium
claws and in doing so basically attacks
bornen and then kills him right cuts him
in half this is one of those moments
right this guy's just ridiculously
overpowered he's gonna become just some
insane character and so cyclops and uh
and sync end up tracking down stasis
they locate him in his lair a kind of
fight breaks out and that's when we get
the revelation of who stasis really is
like cyclops literally blows the mask
off his face and that's when we end up
finding out that basically dr stasis is
nathaniel essex he's mr sinister but
here's the caveat to this here's where
this gets really really really cool so
what goes on here is essex right
sinister doesn't know who cyclops is and
he's like do i know you right like do i
i have no idea who you are and that what
happens is that as they start fighting
with each other that cyclops you know
keeps referring to him is like some
clone that went awry but what essex does
here is he says no i'm the real essex
like i'm the actual nathaniel essex i
don't know who you are but i'm the
actual nathaniel essex now this is a
monumental thing that's going on here
and the reason why is because in marvel
comics the relationship between
nathaniel essex and cyclops is an
exceedingly old relationship right like
literally nathaniel essex whole story
throughout like the entirety of the 80s
right his introduction from marvel
comics throughout the 70s the 80s
running all the way up to the modern era
is that essex had realized that if jean
grey and cyclops ever had a child their
child would be godly powerful it would
be absurdly powerful it's always been
the cornerstone of his obsession with
cyclops and gene and so he's always
trying to find a way to initiate a
coupling or to use their genetic
material to to basically create a clone
different things along those lines right
in the age of apocalypse he successfully
did that nate gray x-man from the age of
apocalypse storyline he's the answer to
the question what if gene grey and
cyclops had a kid and that kid had
untapped power what this basically means
here is that if this really is the real
nathaniel essex then it means the
nathaniel essex that we know of the one
who's obsessed with jean grey and scott
summers it's always been a clone that
has never been the actual nathaniel
essex hence the reason why they look
different right the nathaniel essex that
we know that where they're most familiar
with has a diamond shaped object on his
head that nathaniel essex here has like
a clover leaf on his head it has like a
clover sitting there so it explains why
they look different now there is a kind
of argument that's created here by essex
that like that version of him right
that's all like the quiet council the
one that we've always known is just some
twisted screwed up version but this
argument or this pr this this kind of
presentation that this is the actual
essex it does make sense if you go back
and you look at the old stuff say for
example like the events that led up to
weapons plus right the things that led
up to like like wolverine and stuff like
that right post world war ii at least
during world war ii when nathaniel essex
was working in the concentration camps
and he was experimenting on mutants who
had been captured by the germans even
though the germans didn't really know
what they were trying to understand the
mutant genome and so on and so forth
trying to crack the code that there
wasn't really a whole lot of explanation
as to how it was we went from that essex
to the one that we most commonly see now
it was just kind of like he was obsessed
with the human genome and like that was
it right so it makes perfect sense that
like this is the actual real nathaniel
essex and the other one is just kind of
a clone that basically went rogue and
did his own thing we don't know and in
fact we still don't have an answer to
that we'll likely get one but the
reality here is that this essex while he
he doesn't really see himself as a
mutant or doesn't really present himself
as a mutant and in fact he's staunchly
anti-mutant now the truth here is that
if this really is the original essex he
was created by apocalypse but his body
was modified by apocalypse but he's not
an actual mutant he's basically just a
guy that had his but his genes modified
by apocalypse to give him powers so it
would make sense that he is staunchly
anti-mutant because at his core he's
human there's no x gene in nathanael
essex and there never was and so
ultimately once cyclops and those guys
basically bail because essex ends up
detonating all these bombs in this
facility and then of course it puts a
bunch of innocent lives in jeopardy on
the surface the cyclops in them take off
and that essex basically disappears
right he ends up you know kind of going
away and then traveling back to the
orcas base where he meets with everybody
and they're just kind of like he's kind
of like yep you know we just had another
run in with the x-men and it was a bit
of a failure but in the end we'll still
recoup right we'll still get it back
together and we'll still you know we'll
still target the x-men properly as far
as ben eurek goes because of the guilt
that uh that that you know everett feels
that what they end up doing is revealing
what it was that that had been done to
ben nyrick that his mind had been wiped
all the information is returned to him
and ben urich is allowed to write his
story the undercurrent here and what's
so interesting about this is that it
really is the x-men playing politics
because no way they would have allowed
this to happen if the story was going to
be a hatchet job on the x-men if it was
going to be ben uric literally like
dumping on the x-men and just being like
these selfish bastards have the cure for
death and they will share for anybody
they will share with anybody else out
there no way the x-men would have let
that been published right so it's just
one of those things where it's like
everybody has an agenda whether they
want to admit it or not so it's a really
really cool situation here this is jerry
dugan just cramming a ton of stuff by
the way this is us leaving out
everything that has to do with game
world right so yeah jerry doogan just he
crams too much stuff into a singular
story i don't know why he does that you
know i have no idea why that's the case
but he just does too much he treats
every single story arc like it's the
only story arc he has to write a story
and it's and it just makes things overly
complicated and just way too difficult
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace
you